i'm making this video for one reason so
that you can link to it when people [ __ ]
on you and doubt you i am tired of
people not starting and living their
life on one very simple thing which is
they're worried about what other people
think are you really not gonna live your
life based on somebody's anonymous
feedback that you suck they [ __ ] suck
there's free [ __ ] trash that's why i
[ __ ] found a dumpster let them come
to me so i can say to them are you
serious you literally have time to leave
negative reviews on other people's [ __ ]
is your [ __ ] so [ __ ] up that you take
your time to allocate poison and
negativity on other people's stuff get
out of the way and let people do their
thing it doesn't matter what they think
when you're [ __ ] 92 and you're
sitting there you're not gonna give a
[ __ ] about what punkman96
had to say please take the passion that
is pouring out of my [ __ ] face right
now and run with it and go do something
money ain't time ain't [ __ ] of holding
you back compared to your worry about
other people's opinions it's time to go